this is why women need to be very
careful who they keep around because a
lot of time you're in competition with
each other and misery loves company
whenever a woman now on social media
when they see like a famous woman in a
happy relationship you see them all the
time trying to bring him down trying to
catch him cheating they want to be at
the same level because it's jealousy
misery loves company and so a lot of the
friendships that women have they aren't
productive whatsoever a lot of them are
feeding garbage when you get at a
breakup when you have problems with your
boyfriend and you go talk to your
girlfriends what do they say leave him
leave him right now let's go to the club
they don't actually promote anything
positive they just want to bring you
back to degeneracy